uh broadband on tyneside for a speech to
business after a tough few weeks the pm
perhaps keen to turn the page uh
but which page forgive me
forgive me
and then completely off script
i don't know if you've been to peppa pig
world who's been depends i've anyways
been to pep a big world
not enough
i was well it's fantastic i was a bit
hazy when i would find a peppa pig world
but i loved it and peppa pig world is is
very much my kind of place it has uh
very safe streets
safe and happy at peppa pig world but
back in the world of politics there is
some danger in your speech to the cbi
you lost your notes you lost your place
you went off on a tangent about peppa
pig
frankly is everything okay
i think that uh i think that people uh
got the vast majority of the the points
i wanted to make and i thought i thought
it went over well
but it's not going well with his party
or with voters flagship policy promises
hitting the buffers in delivery
disappointment across the north of
england at scaled down plans for rail
investment and the spiraling fallout
from his botched attempt to replace the
system for disciplining mps
a plan for social care that doesn't
protect the poorest from catastrophic
costs the pm's opponents happy to
capitalize i think there are many many
people that realize this isn't a plan
today we've seen a broken promise from
the prime minister i suspect we're going
to see more because every day every week
we see another broken promise from this
prime minister a string of unforced
errors and broken policy promises the
adulation that boris johnson once
enjoyed amongst his mps is giving way to
a far more transactional relationship
the fear setting in
over there that this electoral asset
risks becoming an electoral liability
mps are losing patience as one senior
conservative said to me today it's bad
not irreversible but this is a pm who
needs to sharpen up his act and quickly
this a politician whose flamboyant style
has beaten off more robotic competitors
but his greatest strength proving his
greatest weakness too
his party now demand in focus beth rigby
sky news westminster